since January the 6th 2021 when Trump
supporters stormed the U.S Congress and
successfully interrupted the
certification of Joe Biden's Victory a
debate has raged were the shocking
scenes simply the result of a
demonstration by enraged Trump
supporters that grew out of control or
was it a concerted attempt to stop the
peaceful transition of presidential
power through violence up to now many of
the hundreds who've been prosecuted have
faced charges ranging from low-level
offenses relating to trespassing and
disorderly conduct to felonies relating
to violence and interrupting
Congressional proceedings but with this
successful prosecution of right-wing
Oath Keepers militia leader Stuart
Rhodes and his Deputy on seditious
conspiracy prosecutors have convinced
the jury that at least some involved
that day did have a plan to oppose the
transfer of Presidential Power by force
evidence was provided showing roads
Railing at the election result and
calling for a Revolution and the chaos
of January the 6th presented an
opportunity prosecutors argued even if
Rhodes was simply being opportunistic
amid the chaos
it's a very substantial victory for the
justice department and it bodes well for
future cases another seditious
conspiracy case against other Oath
Keepers is scheduled to start on Monday
it is a very rare charge the last time
we had a successful prosecution for
seditious conspiracy was in 1995 over an
attempted bombing in New York City by
Islamic militants all five defendants
were found guilty of obstructing an
official proceeding but three were found
not guilty of seditious conspiracy and
defense lawyers pointed out that Rhodes
himself did not enter the capital nor
have prosecutors alleged any plot to do
so Mr Rhodes did not commit the crime of
seditious conspiracy there was no
evidence introduced to indicate that
there was a plan to attack the Capitals
Rhodes faces up to 20 years in prison as
lawyers say he will appeal the verdicts
sherbertansi Al Jazeera Washington